ohoho color palette that made a massive
difference hi my name is Chris healthy
no no you know your life is different
now you shouldn't ever love this video
you get it I made a video like this in
the past of why I can't be a teacher to
me it's very accurate so I decided to
make another one why I can't be a guy
but the real reason 7 is because I shot
a video over at clever TV earlier this
morning and they did full guy
transformation prosthetics and makeup on
me and I didn't want to let that go to
waste
and that's how this idea was born now
that I'm like talking this through I
know there's gonna be these are sweeping
generalizations and shallow stereotypes
so I hope that you know this is
light-hearted just so so so funny it's
up deprecating on me there's no ill
intention here at all whatsoever
please just keep that in mind what a way
to start a comedy video all good comedy
starts with a long list of trigger
warnings another handy we're like
mechanically savvy car won't start
gotta burn it I'm not strong physically
dammit dammit or emotionally hey I am
NOT courageous or brave someone's in the
house excuse me could you please leave
you just take it you can take the TV I
don't think I could do this hard to have
you a whole bunch I have terrible aim
that's everywhere it's all over the seat
it's everywhere I wouldn't have
self-control damn it not the best
watcher of sports go guy good toss
supposed to kick it the result hugging
each other a lot go we're don't I don't
know boring yeah a commercial can't
don't want to and won't sexualized women
like my equal so there you go guys there
are some gross generalizations and
stereotypes on why I can't be a guy
take away lesson men please be kind to
women if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up and make sure you subscribe to
this YouTube channel and make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes
click that Bell notification so you get
notified when it really does hop it
leave a comment down below on why you
couldn't be a thing other than that I
don't know excuse me my eyes are down
here this is a sweatshirt but I am now
selling on represent comm such I don't
know you can get it in red you can get
it in green you can get it in great and
get it in navy blue link is in the
description below it's a limited flash
sale this might be my favorite design
that I've made with represent I hope you
guys enjoy it please go check it out if
you're interested they make great gifts
for the holiday season these will be
here before Christmas I think don't hold
me to that
let's just all assume you know happens
you when you assume you get ass can't
get a boner that's not what boners look
like this is horrifying
I look like Charles Manson oh my god I
would just be doodling all damn day
ouch my boner